bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux de gosse
aujourd'hui je suis très heureuse de
recevoir une invitée sur la chaîne la
personne d'eléonore bienvenue à toi
merci elyonor qui est doctorante en
sciences du langage et ensemble
aujourd'hui nous allons explorer la
manière dont s'influencent mutuellement
la langue et la langue française et la
société la manière dont le langage la
dimension genre et de la langue
influencent nos représentations et nos
perceptions tout à fait donc pour
comment cette vidéo on a un petit
exercice à vous faire faire un petit
scénario on va vous laisser rentrer dans
l'histoire un père et son fils partent
en voyage à la campagne sur le chemin
ils ont un accident le père meurt mais
le fils survie et est amené à l'hôpital
arrivée à l'hôpital un chirurgien de
garde se présente et dit je ne peux pas
opérer c'est mon fils comment cette
situation est-elle possible
alors la réponse à cette question c'est
fait le chirurgien de garde alors ça
peut être le marine si on
réfléchit dans une perspective d'un
couple homosexuel mais ça peut être
aussi la mère de l'enfant si on se place
dans une autre perspective qui est celle
de l'utilisation ou du masculin ici le
chirurgien de garde pour désigner de
manière entre guillemets neutre une
personne quel que soit son genre donc
que ce soit un homme ou une femme est
ici en l'occurrence une femme ce qui
conduit donc à un visibiliser en fait la
présence des femmes notamment pour ce
type de profession qui est des
prophéties une profession hautement
valorisées dans notre société et dans
laquelle les femmes sont sous
représentées donc là on voit bien que le
fait d'utiliser le masculin comme
généralités influence de représentation
puisque tout de suite enfin en fonction
de comment vous avez réfléchi à cette
énigme si vous avez imaginé un homme
aussi juste à vous a bloqué dans comment
cette histoire est possible c'est bien
parce que la langue ici au masculin vous
empêche d'imaginer une femme chirurgien
et en fait ça donc c'est une expérience
qui est tiré de ce livre le cerveau
pense-t-il au masculin donc écrit par
gygax du fleuret et gabriel et qui
permet d'explorer un petit peu justement
ces rapports entre langage est pensé et
la question de est ce que notre langue
la langue française qui est extrêmement
genre et est binaire peut influencer nos
représentations et notamment en fait la
question principale que pose ce livre
c'est cette utilisation du masculin avec
sa valeur qu'on appelle générique c'est
à dire pour parler au pluriel d'un
groupe composé d'hommes et de femmes par
exemple en quoi est-ce que ça influence
nos représentations des groupes dont
parle c'est à dire si je vous parle d'un
groupe au masculin comme si je vous dis
les musiciens est ce que vous allez
imaginer spontanément un groupe composé
uniquement d'hommes ou un groupe composé
d'hommes et de femmes dans quelles
proportions et c'est comme ça évidemment
c'est quelque chose qu'elle c'est super
difficile d'avoir accès évidemment on
peut pas avoir accès comme sa
représentation des personnes et donc
c'est ce que fait un peu la
psycholinguistique pour chercher des
dispositifs méthodologique en fait pour
essayer d'avoir accès un petit peu à ces
représentations
par des méthodes scientifiques en fait à
six a déjà posé la question mais en
fonction d'un des systèmes linguistiques
qui nous en français c'est vrai qu'on a
un genre mais c'est pas le 1 oui on a
deux genres en tout cas dans la langue
française mais ce n'est pas le cas dans
toutes les langues et forcément ça
influence la manière dont on se
représente les choses en français on a
un système qui fournit sur deux jours
avec la fameuse ray qu'on a toutes et
tous entendu à l'école de le masculin
l'emporté sur le féminin et attends ça
se dire je pense que bon bah c'est une
règle de grammaire c'est comme ça alors
que c'est quelque chose qui est
construit finalement oui tout à fait
c'est une règle qui n'a pas toujours été
la seule utilisée dans la langue
française on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
de l'accord de proximité donc c'est le
fait d'accorder un adjectif avec le
dernier nom le nom le plus proche en
fait
dans la phrase donc typiquement au lieu
de dire en français les hommes et les
femmes sont beaux avec l'accord de
proximité on pourrait dire les hommes et
les femmes sont belles femmes étant le
mot le plus proche de l'adjectif c'est
un accord qui existait déjà dans la
langue française à peu près jusqu'à la
renaissance qu'est-ce qui a fait que on
est passé de cet accord en tout cas ces
types d'accords un peu différent si j'ai
bien compris on n'appelait pas qu'un
mais voilà à aujourd'hui la règle
vraiment strict de on accorde masculin
quand il ya un groupe avec même 99
femmes et un homme est ce qu'il ya eu un
moment précis dans l'histoire ou où ça a
été entérinée par la loi alors en fait
on parle beaucoup du xviie siècle qu'un
moment où notamment avec la création de
l'académie française et on va dire le
pouvoir symbolique accordés à des
grammairiens il ya un discours sur la
langue profondément misogyne qui se met
en place et notamment avec cette célèbre
formule de vaugelas le genre masculin
étant le plus noble doit prédominer
toutes les fois que le masculin et le
féminin se trouvent ensemble ça ça date
de 1647 il ya vraiment une
on va dire une volonté
misogyne ici de valoriser le masculin au
détriment du féminin après il faut aussi
relativiser l'importance de ces discours
là parce que la langue elle est faite
des usages des locuteurs et des
locutrice avant tout avant la
législation avant les dictionnaires il
ya eu ce discours misogyne qui a pris
quand même une place très importante
notamment dans l'enseignement aussi de
la langue française dans les écoles
comme tu disais cette phrase le masculin
l'emporté sur le féminin je pense que
c'est plus quelque chose qui se dit tel
quel dans les écoles aujourd'hui on ne
formule pas de cette manière là parce
que c'est une manière de formuler qui
est sexiste mais voilà cette règle
continue à être enseigné il ya une
deuxième logique qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est le fait que les langues
évoluent continuellement et elle évolue
en fait en se simplifiant de plus en
plus donc on peut aussi voir cette
prédominance du masculin dans la langue
avec cette idée que le masculin serait
aussi un genre neutre en fait que le
masculin pourrait à la fois désigner le
masculin et des hommes dans la langue
mais aussi avoir ce pouvoir de
représenter la neutralité et ça ça peut
aussi être interprétée comme la
simplification progressive de la langue
peut-être même vers une langue qui au
bout n'aurait plus de genre et n'aurait
que le masculin qui serait un genre
neutre c'est notamment d'ailleurs ce qui
a été fait il me semble en finlande où
il ya une suppression par par l'état du
féminin pour essayer d'éviter ces
représentations spécifiques alors du
coup on évite les représentations
spécifiques mais en choisissant voilà le
manager bjarne est d'ailleurs les études
de psycholinguistique en finlande montre
que
les représentations en fait spécifique
n'ont pas complètement disparu non plus
fait on a toujours tendance à se
représenter des sommes majoritairement
malgré la suppression du femina en fait
parce que du coup l inverse on pourrait
se dire qu'on pourrait justement choisir
le féminin pour essayer de vallauris
davantage mais s'il usage l'emportent et
qu'on n'utilise plus le masculin par
exemple est ce que c'est la main quand
une simplification est ce que c'est la
même chose par exemple pour les noms de
métiers qui on le voyait au moyen-âge
avait plus de noms avec des équivalences
féminine par exemple on me disait il
semble doctoresse au physicienne et au
fur et à mesure c'est des mots qui ont
disparu est-ce que c'est là aussi la
simplification dans ce sens on va garder
un seul terme le masculin pour englober
les deux praticiens et praticiens et
praticiennes bas là il me semble que
cette logique là elle est beaucoup plus
difficile à admettre l'idée que ce soit
une simplification parce que pour le
coup la langue française elle reste
quand même profondément
jean rey est binaire et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que justement
jusqu'au xviie xviiie siècle il existait
vraiment concernant les noms de métiers
un mot masculin et un mot féminin
suivant un système très très régulier en
fait deux binômes de père voilà qu'ils
étaient réguliers logique et c'est là
pour le coup qui nous montrent que c'est
pas une simplification général de la
langue c'est la différence en fait
sociologique dans le sens où est cette
suppression des termes féminin n'a
concerné que les professions valoriser
un rituel social et symbolique
exactement c'est à dire que vraiment le
mot boulangère n'a jamais disparu alors
que le mot autrice oui donc le mot
actrice qui fait beaucoup parler nous
semble-t-il existait en fait dans la
langue française au moyen âge oui tout à
fait et donc ça c'est notamment l'étude
de aurore et 20 on pourra peut-être
mettre des articles en descriptions qui
a vraiment faire un gros travail pour
montrer d'où vient ce mot et comment il
a évolué depuis le latin parce que même
en latin on avait octore oct rites qui a
évolué ensuite en eau trice de manière
tout à fait régulière aussi dans la
langue en fait est là encore
passage d'ontologie un peu plus tardive
donc ça date de 1800 1 donc on est
vraiment au tout début du 19e siècle et
donc c'est sylvain maréchal qui écrit un
projet d'une loi portant défense
d'apprendre à lire aux femmes donc on se
situe quand même sur ok voilà un
contexte très particulier et donc il
écrit pas plus que la langue française
la raison ne veut qu'une femme soit
auteur ce titre sous toutes ses
acceptions est le propre de l'homme seul
donc on voit vraiment que cette
évolution en faveur d'une disparition du
motrices qui s'est fait pour le coup
dans les dictionnaires et qui petit à
petit
à influencer la société c'est vrai que
tout à l'heure je disais l'importance et
les usages etc et il faut relativiser
l'importance des dictionnaires ou des
discours sur la langue mais bien sûr
qu'ils ont quand même un impact aussi et
que le fait qu'on puisse pas trouver le
mot au tri dans le dictionnaire a
peut-être aussi
influencé son effacement progressif de
la langue française et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en fait les
premiers mouvements alors ce qu'on
appelait à ce moment-là de féminisation
de la langue mais aujourd'hui des
chercheuses hommes éliane viennot disent
qu'il faudrait plutôt parler de des
masculinisation de la langue ce
processus donc qu'on appelait à l'époque
de féminisation de la langue en fête a
commencé au au québec avec des
féministes qui se sont dit mais c'est
pas possible en fait de ne pas avoir
d'équivalent féminin pour certains mots
et qui pense et à ce moment là comme
n'avait pas encore vu ses études sur
l'histoire de la langue que ces mots là
n'avait pas existé c'est de là qu'est né
le néologisme auteur e avec un e à la
fin est en fait tous ces néologismes
viennent du québec ingénieur e
professeur eu en face sur néologisme
peut-être pour si tu veux expliquer ce
que c'est un des nouveaux mots voilà un
mot nouveau qui a inventé un voilà qu'on
peut dater on va dire à mon récent que
c'est donc là serait que hauteur par
exemple si on vous demande non mais tu
veux pas à place dotrice dire auteurs
eux on pouvait la faune mais c'est un
néologisme moi j'utilise le mot qui
vient du latin après le fait que ce soit
un néologisme donc un mot nouveau c'est
pas forcément un problème en soi
l'argument comme quoi au tri c'est un
mot plus anciens aussi être contestées
enfin c'est pas forcément un argument
qui a valeur d'autorités absolue parce
que le terme auteur en fait c'est quand
même relativement bien diffusée
notamment au québec enfin le canada
francophone auteur e ingénieur e
professeur écrire à ces deux termes qui
sont qui ont été très utilisé cet
argument historique
il parle en fait beaucoup aux
francophones l'idée de ce quelque chose
qui existait déjà dans la langue je
pense que ça a une portée pour
le légitimer ça c'est sûr après de mon
point de vue aussi de l'enseignante de
français
c'est aussi un terme qui est peut-être à
privilégier par rapport à hauteur eux
dans le sens où il correspond à la
logique de la langue c'est à dire que
vous avez peut-être vu ses collages on
dit acteurs actrices pourquoi on ne
dirait pas hauteur au triste à dire que
en effet les noms de profession enter
dans la langue française fondatrice sous
leurs formes féminines c'est un système
grammaticales entériné en matière donc
de ce point de vue là autrice correspond
aussi à un système plus logique que
auteurs eux qui est fait là encore un
petit peu exception est le troisième
argument dans ce dans ce débat c'est à
dire je pense pas vraiment débat entre
auteurs eux et au triste c'est une
question qui s'est posée en tout cas
quand même dans la société c'est la
question de la sonorisation bien sûr
parce que en fait quand on dit une
hauteur
alors avec l'article on entend mais le
féminin est un peu plus discret par
exemple si on dit l'auteur du livre à
l'oral on ne sait pas si c'est l'auteur
où l'auteur exactement du coup avec
autrice le son est présent et je pense
que c'est pour ça que ça crispe
certaines personnes qui peuvent être un
peu réfractaires à l'it à l'idée
d'utiliser au triste c'est que bah oui
c'est un féminin assumer en quelque
sorte et dans cette logique de
visibiliser les femmes et en particulier
les autres is oublié c'est vrai que la
sonorisation peut aussi avoir un impact
plus important le fait qu'on l'entende à
l'oral la différence c'est qu'on entende
qu'on parle bien d'une table une fois
qu'on a dit que la langue avait évolué
de telle manière à ce que maintenant
elle soit sexiste du fait de
l'invisibilisation parle usage ou par
les règles du féminin question les
manières qu'on a aujourd'hui est de
rendre justice aux femmes en quelque
sorte et d'inclure davantage les femmes
dans le langage il ya eu un mouvement en
fait évolutif alors comme je vous le
disais tout a commencé au québec il faut
le dire clairement elles ont été
précurseurs par rapport aux françaises
sur cette question-là majoritairement au
début sur de la création du coup de
nouveaux noms de métiers au féminin donc
ça ça va être un premier mouvement assez
important qui s'est développée au québec
du coup dès les années 70 en france
aussi a commencé à avoir un peu de
recherche sur cette question des
rapports entre les mots et les femmes
c'est un ouvrage de marina bellot qui
datent de 74,6 je dis pas de bêtises
donc on se situe à peu près au milieu
des années 70 ces réformes concernant la
féminisation ou là des masculinisation
des noms de métiers elles ont été très
très vite adoptée par les institutions
notamment au québec par l'office
québécois de la langue française qui les
a recommandé puis assez rapidement dans
les années 80 aussi par la belgique et
la suisse en france en gros au milieu
des années 1980 il ya une commission de
terminologie qui est créé avec benoît de
groupe qui est chargée donc de créer en
fait des fins de réfléchir à la création
de néologismes concernant les noms de
métiers féminins mais en fait cette
commission a elle est très très vite
critiqué
dévalorisée par l'académie française
est-ce que juste avant qu'on parle de
l'académie française que je pose une
question on mène on sait comment ça se
fait même que ce soit au canada
francophone en suisse et en belgique
qu'on est mené sur réflexion avant le
pays dont le français est la langue
officielle unique je pense que c'est une
veste qui pensent que justement la
france est à ces prisonnières notamment
de l'académie française en fait
concernant la
réglementation va dire le lusage c'est
vrai qu'en fait ça s'explique beaucoup
par notre histoire la langue française
est intimement liée à la création de la
république on le sait assez peu parce
qu'en fait on parle beaucoup de villers
cotterêts le moment où la langue
française devient la langue de
l'administration
quand j'ai peur de partir un peu lourde
pour cette réponse mais bon
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
l'on en a fait un peu un mythe du moment
où ça y est en france tout le monde va
parler français et c'est alors qu'en
fait c'était pas du tout le but de cette
réforme le but de cette réforme c'était
au contraire garder cet usage du
français pour une élite et pas du tout
de le démocratiser et de l'enseigné
à la population française jusque là la
population française parle est plein de
langues nationales de dialectes
exactement c'est finalement pas du tout
une période où le français devient la
langue du peuple français par contre
c'est quelque chose qui se produit à la
révolution française pour le coup là ça
accompagne en fait le projet de
démocratisation de la france et le en
fait pour encourager les la population
française a participé à la vie civique
enfin les hommes de la population
français bon c'était un peu une belle
idée qui finalement a mis pas mal de
temps avant de d'être vraiment en mise
en application et dans sa mise en
application même y aurait aussi beaucoup
de choses à redire parce que en fait la
diffusion de la langue française et de
l'enseignement de la langue française à
toute la population en particulier aux
couches les moins aisées de la
population s'est accompagnée de la
répression en fête des langues
minoritaires et jusqu'à aujourd'hui en
fait cette question des langues
régionales c'est une question qui est
très sensible en france on ne sait assez
peu mais en fait la france un des seuls
pays peut-être même le seul qui a refusé
de signer la charte des langues
régionales et minoritaires en europe et
en fait ça accompagné dès que
les langues minoritaires
favoriserait le communautarisme et donc
la division de notre société et de notre
république
c'est en position à l'universalisme
républicain révolutionnaire exactement
hockey est en fait c'est l'argument qui
est aussi invoqué pour lutter contre le
langage inclusif c'est jean michel
blanquer qu'il a parfaitement illustré
dans un de ses tweets il ya une seule
langue française une seule grammaire une
seule république dans un discours sur la
langue qui est
hemming ici par notre ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui est de
vraiment dire là l'unité de la nation
dépend aussi de l'unité de la langue et
ce faisant il présente aussi
implicitement le langage inclusif comme
une autre langue qui ne serait pas du
français ce qui est quand même aussi
une question intéressante ça comme si le
fait de alors je pense qu'il parle pas
ici de la féminisation des noms de
métiers mais plutôt de des stratégies
pour éviter l'utilisation du masculin
pluriel pour parler d'un groupe mixte
notamment avec le fameux point médian je
pense que c'est plutôt ce à quoi il fait
référence quand il s'attaque ici à
l'écriture inclusive et donc c'est
intéressant parce que implicitement il
présente ça comme étant quelque chose
qui n'est pas du français qui serait
comme une autre langue qui viendrait
menacer l'unité de la république alors
même que en tant que sociologue tu peux
en parler aussi tout le monde ne parle
pas du tout le français de la même
manière et le français qu'elle fait en
fait référence gens que j'aime blanc car
dans ce tweet c'est le français de
l'académie française dont tu parlais
tout à l'heure oui tout à fait donc
l'académie française parce que du coup
on a fait une très grande parenthèse
avec la question mais l'académie
française en tant qu'institution est ce
que tu peux nous rappeler brièvement ce
que c'est et à quoi ça sert alors
l'académie française donc elle a été
créé au xviie siècle par le cardinal
richelieu c'est vraiment un projet
idéologique qui est au service du
pouvoir royal et qui est de
d'enrichir la langue française qui est à
cette époque là considérée comme la plus
belle la plus la rupture etc et donc il
s'agit de l'enrichir de la rendre encore
plus belle encore plus pur et du coup
les académiciens et académicienne
l'at-il fait il
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
il ya en tout cas aujourd'hui très peu
de langues 8 voire aucun je me demande
si on a pas un qui a rentré très
récemment mais voilà en tout cas c'est
une institution qui accueille en son
sein en particulier des écrivains et
quelques écrivaine
des membres du clergé généralement des
des intellectuels et surtout essayer des
hommes politiques et des enfants de
personnalités politiques jeudi leur
mission qu'est ce que c'est à l'époque
actuelle alors à l'origine comme leur
mission c'est est d'enrichir et de
cadres et on va dire qu'un de donner des
règles à la langue française
il était censé écrire un dictionnaire
une grammaire et il me semble aussi une
poétique donc de manière assez régulière
sauf que jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ya eu
une seule grammaire qui a été publiée au
début du 20e siècle mais qui a été
complètement décrié par les linguistes
et sinon donc l'académie française
publié un dictionnaire mais alors on
peut dire que c'est vraiment les plus
lents a publié un dictionnaire
encore en train d'écrire la nouvelle
édition donc autant vous dire que quand
elle sera publiée elle sera déjà
obsolète enfin on va dire elle ne
permettra pas de faire entrer des termes
qui sont pourtant courant aujourd'hui
dans le vocabulaire donc on peut aussi
se demander
à quoi on les paye est ce que cette
institution elle coûte cher en fait ils
ont que l'académie française depuis le
début dans ses missions elle a un rôle
prescriptif donc l'idée qui est qu'elle
va créer des termes créer des règles un
rôle en fait comme si c'était une
institution qui devait légiférer sur la
langue
alors qu'aujourd'hui les dictionnaires
revendique plutôt d'avoir une vision
descriptive c'est à dire que le but
n'est pas d'imposer un mot dans l' usage
puisque on voit bien que c'est celle
usages qui prime avant tout par exemple
quand coville
exactement que le fait que l'académie se
soit prononcé sur la coved alors que l'
usage majoritaire et locaux vides
exactement donc tout ça pour dire que
l'académie française n'est pas est à la
fois l'institution qui régit est les
règles du français
tiens on appelle attention voilà mais
qui est plutôt réfractaire au changement
par l' usage et j'imagine nouvelle
proposition un peu alternative ou
dissidente concernant la grammaire et le
vocabulaire français oui c'est aussi
parce que comme je devais aller
tellement lente que en fait elle n'a pas
là non plus l'occasion de vraiment faire
rentrer les nouveaux usages
dansez dansez dictionnaire on l'a vu le
temps que l'âme est très bon ça commence
un bon pain tout doucement arrivé aussi
jusqu'aux sphère de l'académie française
et notamment en 2019 donc l'académie a
fini par publier une circulaire
concernant la féminisation des noms de
métiers mais voilà en 2019 alors que au
québec en suisse en belgique savait
depuis les années 80 voire 90 que
ça a été entérinée par point de vue
institutionnel quand on est donc le
fameux point médian on en parlait tout à
l'heure crise peut pas mal de vous aviez
académiciens et académicienne c'est pas
tout à fait alors bon le point médian si
on revient rapidement sur cette cette
polémique la polémique elle est née en
france en 2010 est avec la publication
d'un manuel d'histoire des éditions
attiré qu utiliser le pain alors même
pas le point médian d'ailleurs le point
bas le point final dans certains de ces
titres mais c'était vraiment en plus
quelque chose de très très marginale à
l'échelle du manuel et en fait ce manuel
a été publié en utilisant ce type de
formulation en tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'il l'a justifiée en disant qu' il
respecté les recommandations du haut
conseil à l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes donc ça vous pouvez le
consulter pour mettra peut-être aussi un
lien en 2015 le haut conseil à l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes a publié
un guide de rédaction inclusive dans
lequel il recommande donc plusieurs
choses notamment le fait donc la
féminisation des noms de métiers mais
aussi par exemple le fait d'utiliser des
pardon d'utiliser l'expression droits
humains au lieu de dire droits de
l'homme en fait voilà plusieurs
propositions mais aussi le fait
d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle des doublés
c'est à dire de dire le mot au masculin
et au féminin pour montrer qu'on parle
d'un d'hommes et de femmes et pour
lutter contre les billets de
représentations sexistes dont on a déjà
parlé qui peuvent arriver quand on parle
d'un groupe en utilisant le masculin et
sa valeur
soit disant neutre mais qui en fait
créer des biens de représentation par
exemple les musiciens et les musiciennes
les chercheurs et les chercheuses avec
exactement donc il ya eu un petit peu un
encouragement à utiliser plus ce type de
formulation est double et on voit que ça
peut être un vrai enjeu dans le langage
pour lutter contre ces billets de
représentations sexistes
mais voilà il ya eu des critiques qui
ont été formulées notamment sur la
lourdeur que peut introduire ce qu'on
appelle la féminisation des textes donc
le fait de rajouter c'est doublé et à ce
moment là
donc il ya eu cette proposition donc du
point médian donc le point médian c'est
un point qui n'est pas utilisée en fait
dans la langue française mais qui
utilise en d'autres langues dans
d'autres systèmes et qui est en fait qui
se situe au milieu de la ligne à peu
près à la l'équivalent de la barre du 1
e donc c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
médian parce qu'il est au milieu de la
ligne mais en fait depuis très longtemps
on utilise en france les parenthèses pas
répond sur les anciennes cartes
d'identité c'était écrit
et c'est vrai avec entre parenthèses et
personne n'a jamais crié au scandale de
l'écriture invasif des centaines
caressante c'était ça restait les femmes
entre parenthèses pas trop directement
donc c'est pour ça aussi que les
féministes ont critiqué cette
utilisation des parenthèses en disant
que bon c'était certes une avancée dans
la visibilité à sion du féminin dans la
langue mais que symboliquement ce
n'était pas un symbole très positif
parce qu'il contribue encore à enfermer
les femmes départ en toge exactement et
les parenthèses en français c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on utilise pour parler de
quelque chose qui est moins important
dans la phrase donc on restait toujours
sur cette connotation un petit peu
péjorative et il ya eu aussi les
provisions par exemple avec les tirs et
donc à il est tiré les points bas les
point médian bon en fait toutes ces
propositions visent uniquement donc à
abréger les doubler c'est à dire que
voilà au lieu d'écrire les musiciens et
les musiciennes vous pourriez écrire les
musiciens point n s mais le prononcer
simplement les chiens et les musiciennes
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle est
cette crispation je pense que c'est
intéressant de parler d'abréviations ce
que ça permet de les mettre sur le même
plan que toutes les abréviations qu'on a
dans la langue française du type quand
vous écrivez monsieur et que vous
écrivez m points vous ne lisez jamais ça
m point du conte l'argument de dire les
musiciens point enc les y sera en fait
c'est l'origine de ce système qui est un
tout petit ce thème dans le grand
ensemble du langage inclusif
spécialement pour simplifier à
l'écriture est pour raccourcir la stand
est doublé voilà exactement par exemple
au canada on a plutôt préconisé
l'utilisation de ce qu'ils appellent la
balle le langage épicène donc c'est à
dire au contraire de chercher non pas à
valoriser le féminin dans la langue mais
plutôt à un visibiliser les marques de
genre masculin donc par exemple ça va
être l'emploi de termes comme dire la
direction au lieu de dire le directeur
ou la directrice de l'établissement des
mots du type journalistes artistes ce
sont des termes épicène en français don
mello bercy terre pour nous par exemple
exactement donc le langage inclusif et
notamment les propositions féministe de
nom épicène de féminisation des noms de
métiers également de point médian ex
terra ça vient de cette volonté de
rétablir un équilibre sur l'hésitation
du féminin et du masculin dans la langue
oui exactement en très résumé il ya un
truc quand on voulait absolument parler
avec eléonore dans cette vidéo c'est une
proposition assez radical qui a été fait
par une artiste française
de proposer ce qu'elle appelle la
féminine universel cette militante
féministe qui a théorisé créé la famille
universelle et ce mal typhaine b elle
est comédienne et pour expliquer son
choix elle a écrit un texte que je vais
vous lire rapidement a féminine
universel consiste en l'invention d'une
grammaire féministe impertinente de mots
inventer comme femmes âge qui a sûrement
dû exister par le par la passe et pardon
ou encore nous et vous pour rassembler
la peuplent des femmes les sorcières et
les anniversaires pour fêter notre
sororité et toutes autres libertés
féministe ante qui semblera signifiante
émancipatrice à l'autre hills ou
simplement qui lui plaira en est faite
les instigateurs de la masculinisation
du langage sur richelieu ne s'étendent
pas encombrer de logique ou
d'objectivité dans leur sinistre tâche
nul n'y est à son tour tenu dans la
riposte par ailleurs la famille vercel
débris des insurgés un subordonné se
trouve en constante évolution et n'est
pas restreinte par des règles strictes
si ce n'est celle de toujours être
porteuse de sens à lens vers les
intérêts des femmes donc en luttes
féministes radicales intransigeance
contre toute forme des violences ou
d'arnac masculinistes et misogyne donc
la foule ni universelle en grand c'est
une proposition artistique et comme aldi
qui se veut provocatrice et
révolutionnaire vous l'avez peut-être
entendu dans la manière dont j'ai lu le
texte est aussi vous l'avez vu un sous
nos yeux avec une orthographe et une
prononciation une féminisation à
l'extrême des mots qui choquerait notre
cher jean michel pierre et les
académiciens
tout à fait c'est vrai qu est ce qui est
intéressant c'est cette idée
d'impertinence aussi de et voilà c'est
un projet qui
dans sa danse à dans ce manifeste en
tout cas apparaît clairement comme un
projet de lutte féministe contre les
formes de violence masculine c'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'était
féminine universelle c'est pas seulement
quelque chose de déclaratif qu'à laval a
annoncé comme ça un beau jour c'est
qu'elle a fait tout un spectacle dans
laquelle elle utilise la féminine
universel et cette profession
linguistique elle a aussi été utilisé
dans la rédaction d'un livre qui a donc
été publié imprimés avec la féminine
universel et si on suit la logique de
celle usage qui fait la langue est bien
dans notre usage il est un livre publié
la féminine universelle se livrent ces
héroïnes de la rue de la militante
féministe marguerite stern c'est un
livre qui ne parlent pas
particulièrement de la famille
universelle d'un livre dans lequel elle
décrit son parcours militant c'est une
femme qui passait par les femen et qui
la créatrice du décollage contre les
féminicides je vous mets qu'avec les
informations dans la barre d'infos mais
en tout cas marguerite12 tout début de
son livre elle annonce qu'elle va écrire
son livre selon la règle de la féminine
universelle en collaboration avec la
créatrice tiphaine d intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est que en fait à elle elle
explique même qu'elle trouverait ça
illogique et immoral d'écrire un livre
qui prône la féminisation d'un espace
celui de la rue en ne féminise hante pas
en même temps celui qui me permet
d'exprimer mes idées donc c'est assez
intéressant cette idée qu elle fait le
lien en termes de cohérence en fait
entre eux son propos et la langue
qu'elle va utiliser pour décrire
son action de féministes et elle précise
même parce que la langue à cette
fonction structurante et normatifs pour
la pensée nous ne penserons pas féminine
tant que nous ne parlerons pas féminine
donc en faisant le lien entre la langue
et la pensée et en montrant donc
l'importance voilà ce dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure des billets
sexiste dans nos représentations c'est
vraiment la raison pour laquelle elles
vont utiliser donc cette règle de la
féminine qui l'emportent sur la
masculine est ce qui est intéressant
c'est que sept féminines vercel en fait
elle se déploie je dirais sur trois
terrains d'abord un terrain plutôt
lexical donc la question du vocabulaire
tiphaine dès le 10 d'antan le texte que
tu as lu tout à l'heure c'est la paix
universelle elle constitue en
l'invention de deux mots comme femmes
âge donc l'équivalent du terme hommage
mais qui désigne en fait un hommage
envers une femme donc le femmes âge et
c'est intéressant je trouve parce que ce
type de néologismes permet de mettre en
lumière
l'omniprésence des références aux hommes
dans notre langue aussi jusque dans ses
mots comme hommage dans lesquels on ne
voyait pas peut-être la référence à
l'homme en fait qu intéressant c'est
qu'elles vont à la fois utiliser les
travaux donc deux chercheuses comme
aurore et 20 ou éliane viennot sur
l'histoire de la langue et sur les
anciens mot féminin qui ont été conquis
avait disparu de nos pratiques
langagières donc notamment celles qui
ont vraiment contribué à revaloriser les
termes autrice peintre s philosophait ce
fils de fès on se demande bien pourquoi
les thermes a été supprimé par les
académiciens et donc pour aussi voilà
remettre ces termes un petit peu au goût
du jour et
les employés dans un discours féministe
ya trois terrains on va dire sur
lesquels la féminine universelle se
déploie dans l'invention le lexique mais
aussi la grammaire et donc c'est là
aussi que ça devient peut-être plus
subversif on a vu avec toutes nos
histoires sur la démobilisation de nos
métiers à quel point ça avait déjà été
un combat difficile en france à quel
point la remise en question de cette
règle du masculin qui l'emportent sur le
féminin entre guillemets avait été aussi
difficilement acceptée en france avec
cette histoire du point médian là elles
vont beaucoup plus loin ndl reposent
plusieurs choses différentes
premièrement quelque chose qui me
semblait intéressant c'est que l genre
les pronoms qui ne sont pas genre et au
féminin donc comment dire en français on
a des pronoms genre et hillel au
singulier ou au pluriel on a aussi des
pronoms genre et donc tous les autres
jeux tuons nouveau qui est intéressant
c'est que dans la avec la fée universel
tiphaine des marguerites stern et toutes
les personnes qui l'utilisent vont
proposer de nouvelles versions des
pronoms notamment nous vous soit donc
écrite avec un e donc il ya les pronoms
et il ya aussi les adverbes elle
féministes des adverbes comme par
exemple je vous accueille
chaleureusement
ou alors immédiatement immédiatement tu
exactement donc en rajoutant ceux là
encore comme avec les pronoms qui est
intéressant pour moi c'est ce choix de
la marque du jeu en fait si on regarde
la langue française le 1 n'est pas
forcément une marque du féminin il ya
plein de mot féminin qui se termine par
un e mais il ya aussi plein de noms
féminins qui se termine pas du tout paru
par exemple tous les maux ancion en
français sont féminins l'administration
etc c'est intéressant parce que là elles
reprennent
exactement leur peine en fait un cliché
qu'on a sur la langue je pense aussi que
ça une certaine efficacité parce que vu
que c'est un cliché qui est partagé
quand on entend chaleureusement au lieu
de chaleureusement tout le monde peut se
dire ah bah elle féminine est en fête du
coup c'est efficace dans le sens où les
gens comprennent tout de suite quelle
est la démarche dans la grammaire
j'avais aussi autre chose
c'est un dernier point mais qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est la question
dit il un personnel ou unipersonnelle
qu'on utilise par exemple quand on dit
il pleut il fait beau et c'est
un île qui est considéré comme neutre
dans le sens où il ne désigne pas une
personne et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est un petit peu le point de
départ de typhaine n'est en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu elle le raconte pour
la création de la féminine universelle
c'est qu'elle voulait écrire un
spectacle sur les comptes et qu' elle ne
pouvait pas commencé son spectacle en
dix ans il était une fois oui parce que
dès le premier mot pour elle dans cette
réflexion sur la langue et ses
connotations et les représentations
qu'elle pouvait induire on était
directement dans le masculin et c'est là
aussi voilà ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ce film comme on disait il ne
désigne pas une personne qui fait une
action il ne désigne pas une personne
tout court mais c'est la même forme que
celle qui permet au singulier de
désigner un homme par exemple et du coup
elle dit quoi pour il était une fois et
de quoi elle dit elle était ce une fois
écouté ça c'est pour le terrain de la
grammaire et la troisième stratégie cas
qu'elle utilise ses aisselles de
changement dans les expressions elle dit
d'ailleurs elle même les expressions
anciennement misogyne mais aussi raciste
spéciste valide east oppressive en fait
d'une quelconque manière par exemple il
faut rendre à cléopâtre ce qui est à
cléopâtre donc en détournant
l'expression rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar là encore ça lui permet de mettre
en lumière
toutes les références masculine qu'on
peut avoir dans nos expressions elle dit
aussi par exemple au lieu de dire c'est
pas sorcier c'est pas sorcier évidemment
c'est aussi dans une logique on va dire
dans l'approché féministe de
revalorisation de la figure de la
sorcière voir la vidéo sa valeur
anecdotique comme ça mais en fait c'est
tout un ensemble de mots qui structurent
notre imaginaire aussi et toutes ses
expressions qu'on emploie sans même
vraiment y penser qu'on apprend tel quel
canton les renverse et qu'on les
repenser au féminin on se rend compte
que quand même ça en créer des
représentations différentes a fait appel
à un autre type de représentation à
derrière un autre imaginaire en fait
donc pour résumer la féminine
universelle c'est une proposition est
subversive impertinente comme l'additif
end et qui a pour but de nous montrer
l'omniprésence du masculin et des hommes
dans la langue française mais également
l'absence des femmes et du féminin dans
la langue c'est une profession qui a qui
a pas pour objectif de devenir la langue
nationale française c'est vraiment dans
le but d'interpeller et de nous faire
questionnaire veut plus les mots et des
expressions qu'on utilise au quotidien
ouais exactement dans j'espère que si
vous ne connaissiez pas ça ou ça vous
rend un peu curieux d'aller vous
renseigner davantage sur le sujet pour
autant c'est pas la seule proposition
qui lie à pour le langage plus inclusif
oui exactement il ya aussi des
propositions qui visent plutôt à
diminuer la présence du genre dans la
langue notamment on a en parlé tout à
l'heure les propositions de langage
épicène mais aussi des propositions
subversive là encore qui lisent plus tôt
à abolir cette binarité des genres qui
structure la langue française entre le
masculin et le féminin et pour laisser
de la place à d'autres identités de
genre donc notamment le nouveau
prononcée elle qui est rentré dans le
dictionnaire en ligne le robert hay a
déchaîné les foules et le monde et qui
permet à la fois 2
désigner une personne quel que soit son
genre donc c'est la définition proposée
par le robert dans le sens où ça permet
de parler d'une personne dont on ne
connaît pas le genre ou dont le genre ne
serait pas important mais ça permet
aussi de désigner les personnes qui ne
se reconnaissent pas dans la binarité de
genre du masculin et du féminin porté
par la langue française est d'ailleurs
ce prenons il a aussi une fonction
d'abréviations jeu de dire il est les
ailes où ils et elles font quelque chose
c'est aussi utilisé pour dire yale fond
où il ya elle fait donc va merci
beaucoup et les honneur d'avoir partagé
la scène sociaux logos avec moi
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment super
intéressant et écouter parler de tout ça
j'espère que ça vous a plu derrière
votre écran n'hésitez pas à liker cette
vidéo elle a partagé à nous dire ce que
vous avez pensé de nos propos en
commentaire on a vraiment hâte de vous
lire l'espère encore une fois que ça
vous a plu devant le trouve très vite
pour une autre vidéo sur sacerdoce
[Musique]